hallo mein name ist klug und ich habe
schon lange nicht mehr nach zwei uhr
nachts aufgenommen
bis heute jetzt ich habe mal wieder
einen command vorbereitet das heißt wir
geben ein / gfp command unterstrich
block um einen kommentar unter harten
wir den command block holen uns
irgendwie noch schön sonnen blog auf
redstone setzen den schon hingeben den
command ein und setzten den red zum
doktor ich hoffe das klappt ihr mit den
bäumen
aber es sieht so aus als würde es
klappen dieser command ist von dieser
kommandos von dorit engineer bei comand
thema so seitenweise hier könnte schnell
abfotografieren damit ihr schon vorher
wird seit dem command video wir fangen
einfach an schrott blogs bei die red
engineer da seht ihr schon eingeblendet
es ist wirklich der thron blog.com
anklicken zwar witzig dass da stand
right click here to get your items und
ich bin gestorben
ich habe so viel gelacht war das jetzt
einfach nur ein fehler oder soll das
wirklich schon der erste troll gewesen
sein an dieser wand dass wenn ich okay
das ist ein survival friendly koma das
heißt man kann sich die sache mit den
items selber kraft wir fangen mit dem
ersten und zwar brauchen wir dafür ein
hit krank und arm ostens brauchen wir
für alles was wir bündeln will diese
kritiker und dann können wir einfach die
outplacement mit dem am oster
hinschmeißen wir bekommen eine treue
gäste um die chest einzulösen brauchen
wir noch eine jazz setzen die chest hin
bieten uns an die gäste andrücken
rechtsweg liter pro sesseli sieht schon
darauf stirbt ein jetzt beispielsweise
im game und 0 versuche die kiste
aufzumachen bin ich tot das ist quasi
der erste troll sage ich mal der
eingeführt wird also diese treuetest ist
quasi du gehst dahin macht diese tests
auf und wo sind meine armor stenz die
ich hier im wort fallen lassen man will
quasi diese kiste öffnen aber stirbt
halt einfach aufgrund der explosionen
jedenfalls ist das nächste altem was
hinzugefügt wird der strom bett und
dafür muss ich einfach ein latin
schmeißt unter einen arm osten ihr seht
schon ich bekomme throl bett wenn ich
jetzt ein bett beispielsweise hin setze
mich daran sneak und da wieder auch
richtig drauf machen seht ihr schon
darauf ist eine kugel
und wenn ich mich jetzt versuche bei
time sätze sagen wir 20.000 reinzulegen
völlig aus der welt und sterbe ebenfalls
das ganze funktioniert auch im game mode
und 1 also dafür muss es nicht irgendwie
beweisen muss ich nicht im survival mode
sein oder so also das ist quasi das
zweite throl altem einfach kontrollwerte
wenn man sich da rein legt hat man mehr
oder weniger dann albtraum die dritte
sache ist der thronfolge ist und zwar
brauchen wir dafür einen flinten stil
und ein armer stellen wieder
hinschmeißen dann haben wir das stroh
furness von altem setzen ein ofen
einfach hin gebe ich intro bis dahin und
ihr seht schon so jung was passiert denn
hier was soll denn das sein ich gehe
ganz normal wieder in den game mode 0
mache rechtlich auf den ofen denkt mio
ich mache mir was schönes im ofen
rechtsklick allerdings fange ich an zu
brennen anstatt der ofen und irgendwann
bin ich dann noch tot das war das dritte
troll alter etwas hinzugefügt wird das
vierte ist ein slime blockt roll
wenn ich nämlich einen slum ball und
einen arm aus dahin schmeißen bekomme
ich das trotzdem blog atem und das muss
ich jetzt nämlich diesmal einfach nur so
hinsetzt und ihr seht schon jo ok auf
entfernung das ist das live blog wenn
ich allerdings näher rangehen seht ihr
schon das turnt in zunehmend instituts
das wird dann ein glas blog das heißt
wenn ich aus großen teilen oder
runterspringen denken sojus 1 live blog
dann wieder zu einem glas block und ich
bekomme trotzdem den fall schaden das
heißt wenn ich jetzt mal den gamer 0 g
und fallen lassen ich denke dass mein
block verwandelt er sich quasi zu einem
glas block und meinem herzen habe ich
ein paar top form verloren das fünfte
item ist metro crafting table das heißt
ich nehme ein crafting table schmeicheln
wieder zusammen mit dem ostend in und
wenn ich in andere crafting table
dorthin setzen mit dem crafting tatum
der rechtsweg darauf macht steht davor
sein foto haase und wenn ich jetzt
allerdings achtet man auf mit altem
sagen weil auch meine mentale sagen wir
mal rein theoretisch habe ihr die ganze
zeit überall diamanten drin und ich
denke mir jetzt ja oder ist ein crafting
hebeler kann ich die diamanten
sich weiter verwerten clique mit rechts
drauf thanks for items dann denkt sich
der otto normal minecraft spieler
natürlich wiederum eine items sind jetzt
weg das war vielleicht ein toll aber die
mainz nicht so böse da kann ich
natürlich einfach tanks von items klick
diskreditiert to get them back und wenn
ich da drauf klicken
fick dich minecraft das ist quasi auch
schon das fünfte tor item aber wir
kommen direkt weiter zum sechsten und
zwar brauche ich dafür einerseits eine
fackel und wieder einen amors denn und
zwar wenn ich dann die fackel und den
arm aus klein hinschmeißen sich schon
bekomme ich einen troll pumpkin wenn ich
mir jetzt auch einen ganz normalen
partien holen und diesen kampf in
beispielsweise sagen wir mal in der
nacht jetzt irgendwo hin setzte hier
dann dann leuchtet der nicht ganz normal
wissen dass hier so hell hält ohne spaß
wie kann denn das so hell sein oder
kommt mir das rad nur so vor weil ich
das hier gerade im dunkeln spiele aber
ist ja auch egal jedenfalls wenn ich
jetzt hier mich ran sneaker rechtekauf
mache seht ihr schon wenn ich nah an dem
teil dran bin
oder habe ich hier irgendwas komplett
hell gemacht aber doch okay ist wenn ich
jetzt daran die ihr seht ihr schon
passiert dass hier
wenn ich weiter weg hier ist das ding
wieder ein ganz normaler pumpkin aber
wenn ich näher rangehen fängt es an zu
leuchten und hier kommt dieser komische
wächter also so ein kleiner
überraschungsmoment die nächste sache
beziehungsweise die letzte sache die
hinzugefügt wird ist ich gehe mal ganz
kurz zu den gamern 0 und setzte hier ein
paar spinnennetze hin und zwar gut jetzt
habe ich gerade nur einzeln gesetzt aber
das ist egal und zwar wenn ich dadurch
gehe seht ihr schon bekomme ich die
effekte des lohnes und kleine von erst
wenn ich wieder hier ausgehe so jetzt
bin ich wieder draußen seht ihr schon
verschwinden diese effekte wider das
heißt wenn ihr die spinnennetze läuft
bekommt so blöde effekte noch dadurch
dass ihr quasi noch langsamer da noch
länger da drin seit in etwa und die
allerletzte sache die hinzugefügt wird
ich kann nichts abbauen
ich kann witzig ich kann etwas abbauen
aber ich kann kein gras oder kein word
abbauen also das komplett egal ob das
profil eine glasoberfläche ist oder ob
das die vorne wirklich einfach irgendwie
dort ist oder so kann ich nicht abbauen
das ganze zeit ist quasi lässt sich
nicht wie place das heißt man kann sich
nicht ein boden oder so und ich denke
damit haben wir unsere liste komplett
abgearbeitet deswegen würde ich sagen
es ist drei uhr ich muss morgen um acht
uhr aufstehen und passen beim ikea zu
sein
versuche irgendwie noch vier stunden
schlaf zu holen wenn euch das video
gefallen hat würde ich mich definitiv
über eine bewertung freuen und wir sehen
uns in einem nächsten video wieder